[Music]
the ace family okay so this is did you
watch our lawyer's new video on this oh
no spencer cornell he did a whole new
video about the ace family's house
getting foreclosed on the company that
wrote them first of all they got hard
money loans two of them to cover
a 10 million dollar house i also got
insider info from a real estate agent
recently that that knows about the
property oh
they got completely [ __ ] they got
taken for a ride when they bought that
house the nest the next most expensive
house is two million dollars in that
neighborhood oh they spent 10 million
whoa
because the developer just told them
that it was more than i guess it was and
they just were like oh yeah [ __ ] it
we'll pay they got like basically
scammed
paid weight so they took out hard money
loans to buy this house
so they're paying like way higher
interest i guess they told
uh
uh i don't know they told people that
whoever was like writing the underwriter
permits permanent to build they told
them that they weren't actually going to
live there they're just going to film
there and they would city that yeah and
they moved in anyways permanently right
so anyways they defaulted on their loans
they can't pay them so now that uh
company who wrote the biggest loan i
think they wrote them like eight million
dollar hard money loan takes possession
of the house and tries to sell it in an
auction nobody buys it
so somebody else just bought it for
super cheap from the company because
they just want some of their money back
yeah right
um and so he basically goes through he's
like we know why austin [ __ ] this up
like his business right with the boxing
thing nobody got paid he lost a [ __ ] out
of money
but katherine started a makeup company
they're set to make 60 million dollars
in sales this year alone right if they
had just
continued business their first two sales
sold out immediately they made like a
million and a half in half an hour or
something like that right wow she
eventually
after the two sales tries to stage like
a little corporate takeover i guess
and changes all the passwords to the
shopify the uh instagram account the
twitter account mind you she owns 68 of
this business and she invested like 250k
the company the fulfillment company and
everyone that makes the makeup owns the
latter half and they were doing all the
business
so she was set up to literally make
millions like i mean they were gonna do
60 million dollars in sales and she
owned 65 of the company like she was
gonna take home like tens of millions of
dollars right
and for some reason i guess gets in a
disagreement or something tries to take
over the business and now they've uh
dissolved it and she's getting sued by
them for all like the lost royalties
it's unbelievable and so all the
comments on this are like i cannot
believe how hard they both fumbled the
bag it's insane
[ __ ]
is that the definition of hubris is that
what hubris is right or like
your ego is so big that just
oh my god i know
it's not even like a smart it's so petty
it's just
i it gets it's just so insane how easy
it is
not to [ __ ] that up in their position
yeah you guys are in like the best
position ever you have millions of
dollars at your fingertips also how do
you [ __ ] that up also
do you not consult anyone before buying
a home like who's their business manager
like who all the while they have three
[ __ ] children yeah so what are you
doing yeah like are you not you're not
worried about making sure you have
enough
to like
give your kids a great life
no you're more worried about your ego
and about how someone else is
potentially getting a little bit more
than enough revenue off your makeup
business or whatever yeah how do you not
see that you're about to make 60 million
dollars and that's gonna like secure
your family yep
um i guess now is a good time to say uh
despite you know all our complaints i
did get another house got it through an
auction
it's sick i think i've seen it on
youtube before
you know the [ __ ] who bought
that house for like 400 grand is in that
[ __ ] like oh you sucker oh and it's all
bad i'm dude i know the guy who bought
it oh yeah yeah it's just weird
coincidence i was with him last night
and he was like did he get both he was
like yeah we we uh we just bought this
like really i don't know like
problematic like
youtube and i was like who
who's which house he said we bought a
problematic house and i was like what
house and he's like i don't know some
youtube where he did some boxing thing
and i was like awesome broom he was like
yeah yeah crazy they got taken for a
ride when they built it spent way too
much money on it and now it's in this
area that the other like the next most
expensive house is two and a half
million dollars so no one wants to buy
this 10 million dollar house right so
it's not worth anything close to that
so they picked it up like for cheap from
the loan company and i guess they're
gonna try and flip it or something i
don't know do they get both
because two houses it's two houses on
the property
really uh-huh oh i don't know
damn but it's it's it's weird because
it's like a and spencer makes this point
he's like no one
a lot of these athletes and stuff that
go broke they'll build a custom house
that they want and then right it's not
valid not only is it too expensive but
no one wants to buy it because they're
like this is weird yeah there's a house
in my neighborhood like that has been on
the market forever
it's this creepiest scariest like
it's so clearly like a dude who came up
through the coke business it's got like
a mini
strip club in there
it's like the craziest listing i've seen
for a home it looks more like the top of
like a gargoyle building or something
it's so like how did you wake up in that
[ __ ] like homestead would probably buy
that house yeah
nice uh i was gonna say this have you
seen olivia muns quotes from her book i
will fix america's obesity problems by
taking all motorized transport away from
fat people
in turn i will build an infrastructure
of fat tunnels where all the fat people
can walk this will create jobs and
subsequent weight loss
this [ __ ] never left high school yeah
what a what a weird
15 year old thing to say you put that in
a book bro you hired a publishing
company and you were like put this in
there
no this is gonna go crazy what is the
last one everyone is now required to
adopt one asian baby even asians
what
is that just like you know her trying to
be like funny during myspace kind of
thing yeah sounds like it
because you know like they were like ass
comedians that like had done when is
commentary like this when did she
release that book
yeah
she's trying too hard yeah not that you
get a pass for that but
james corden have you heard anything
about him
is it okay
okay granted i don't think this has ever
been verified right we're just like
doing like t spills this is embarrassing
we're a grown man doing tea spills right
here oh come on this [ __ ] is funny dude
it's funny but it's like it's sort of
cringe that we're doing this
wait well we're not like olivia munn
stinks
so he did it like an ama to promote
something this was like last year and
like every single comment was about how
much of an [ __ ] he is and he didn't
reply to a single one
and it's still up
uh james i am the faintest idea here
without register me you're an [ __ ] so
as a professional [ __ ] our bidet's
worth it nice
isn't the shower technically a bidet for
him because
you know
all right
nice i'm just really i've heard that
olivia munn sucks but i'm just kind of
kind of in awe of
those statements from her and that's a
whole book like that yeah
uh
keemstar retired
oh it's just that quick man
that we're gonna put the t on this
[ __ ] we are not doing 20 minutes of t
spill man i can't believe we're doing t
spill bro
and no you know i'm i'm not doing i'm
not doing t spill
you